فنان سوري وصل بموهبته لشهره عربيه
وعالميه يملك في سيرته عمالا رميه ومسرحيه
وسينمائيه ستبقى دائما في الذاكره ضيفنا
هو باسم الخياط فنان عشقت تمثيل صغيرا منذ
الثامنه مشاركا في مسرح الاطفال مسيره
باسل الخياط غنيه بالاعمال التلفزيونيه
والمسرحيه الثمن اخر اعمال الفنان باسل
الخياط والذي اعلنت من الساتو شاهد عن
اقتراب عرضه
[موسيقى]
بنات متاكد متاكد انك مش ناسيه من
النهارده عيد جوازنا
احنا ناكله شويه بس اكيد هلاقيك
[موسيقى]
طول حياتنا يا رانيا
سينمائيه حديثنا اكثر عن باسل لكل محبينكم
معجبينك
حجمهم جدا
وجدي بعمله هيك هيك بتهموني يعني انه جدي
بعملي زياده عن اللزوم مؤخرا
خلصت تصوير مسلسل التمام يعني صار لي فتره
لا باس فيها ما عملت يعني كنت بعيد عن
المسلسلات الطويله بس هي سنه ان شاء الله
راح نطلع على جمهور بمسلسل طويل شويه يعني
ان شاء الله ما نكون يعني تقال عليهم
مسلسل رح يكون طويل من 90 حلقه بس ان شاء
الله تمام
يعني انا شخصيا بشوف انه الحياه ما بتعطيك
كل شيء بتعطيك من طرف تاخذ من طرف ثاني صح
فا بالنسبه للثمن هو يعني هو يمكن رد
الفعل اللي ممكن يصير بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
للحياه للطاقه الجمعيه اللي ممكن تصير
لحتى الواحد دائما يكون في اكشن وفي اكشن
بالنسبه لنا بمسلسل الثمن يعني كله هيدفع
الثمن احنا عندنا هيك شيء بنقول من
المسلسل كله هيدفع الثمن يعني كله هيدفع
ثمن مسلسلات
همم مثل ما قلت قبل شوي بقول انه هذا
المسلسل
الناس في تعبت جدا عندنا وقت كثير طويل
بذلنا جهد كتير كتير مسلسل
بعتقد انه هو قريب من الناس
دراما بسيطه من النوع السهل البسيط ولكن
المؤثر عم ناقش فيه عده قضايا بتنطلق من
علاقه رومانسيه بين رجل وامراه شروط الحب
بيناتهم او شروط العلاقه غير مكتمله فعملش
داعيات هذه القصافه انه
هذا النوع من المسلسلات او خليني اقول لك
همم نوعيه الاعمال همم بتلاقي احسان
استحسان بالنسبه للجمهور بهاي الفتره
خصوصا انه كلا حياتنا بشكل او باخر يعني
همم نعشق الحب من حب الحب اا وكل واحد
عنده الكبيره يعني تبعه وعنده ذاكرته
لنشوف شو راح يعمل هالمسلسل الحب
احساس اكثر من ما هي مكتوبه في اوقات شعر
بس لانه بده يطلع عن النص والي مكتوب
ناخذ المخرج مثلا تركيا معينه انا يمكن
اول مره بحكيها بشكل
واضح انا دائما بطلع على النص يعني ما
بقدر من لما كنت اصلا طالب في المعهد وحتى
الان ما بقدر ما فيني يلتزم همم
دائما باحس انه يعني انا وانتوا هلا
قاعدين بهذا المكان اوكي احنا عندنا عنوان
لا شيء بدنا نحكي فيه ولكن ما بنعرف اوكي
فانا باحب دائما بعملي انه تحديدا كمان
يتعلق بالحوار
بنسبه كثير كبيره لما بلشت الى الان ما
بقدر التزم بالحوار
[موسيقى]